hi I'm Erik Bosse and captain Marvel's
most surprising twist is the many ways
this film connects to the broader MCU
including spoiler warning but you really
have had enough time to go see Captain
Marvel by now guys including the
tesseract the Cosmic Cube the freaking
space stone shows up in this movie for
anyone with more than a passing
knowledge of the history of the MCU you
guys I assume if you're watching this
video
welcome home nerds this appearance is a
serious game changer I'm gonna explain
how the tesseract got here and now
Captain Marvel is a movie revises the
marvel timeline as we know it and what
this could mean for future films and I
get spoiler warning the kids I get
anything right here in your life okay
the early days of the tesseract remain
unchanged the space stone was one of
these six singularities at the dawn of
the universe the Infinity stones
sometime later the space stone became
encased inside the tesseract cube Odin
defeated the frost giants in the tenth
century and decided to leave the
tesseract with the vikings of norway bit
of a weird move in the grand scheme of
things but there's actually a theory
that i've brought up before that the
reason Odin left the space stone on
earth could have been regret after his
own infinity stone quest in pursuit to
conquer the nine realms leading him to
sacrifice his daughter hella
the same way thinness would later
sacrifice his daughter Gamora her
stories poetry rhymes maybe that's true
maybe not but in Norway the tesseract
remained until Hydra led by Red Skull
took it in 1942 he tried to weaponize it
and got flushed through a wormhole
opened up by the space stone and he
ended up on Vermeer where we saw him an
infinity war the tesseract meanwhile
burned through the hull of the Valkyrie
and Howard Stark found it on the ocean
floor and we know Howard continued to
research the tesseract through the 60s
and 70s because we saw a doodle of it
show up in his notes in Iron Man 2 we
all just assume that the tesseract was
generally in shields possession until
the events of the first Avengers but
this Captain Marvel would be just proved
us wrong dead wrong okay so Captain
Marvel establishes that Marvel a Kree
scientist played by Annette Bening was
on earth under the pseudonym of dr.
Wendy Lawson working on project Pegasus
the focus of this project was the
tesseract
with Marvel using its energy to power a
Lightspeed engine that she could use to
help scroll refugees find a new home
world in a remote part of the galaxy
Marvel died in 1989 when she and Carole
were shot down by the Kree Star Force so
the tesseract remained hidden in her lab
a laboratory that was invisible within
Earth's orbit this was until Carroll
Nick Fury and goofs recovered it six
years later in 1995 juice of course is a
flirt Ken with inner mouth and tentacles
allowing him to swallow big stuff
including the tesseract now this
actually clears up some lingering
mysteries we've had about the MCU time
line for example in Captain America
Winter Soldier we learned that Shield
has actually been corrupted by Hydra
throughout the 20th century but if over
all those years the frickin space stone
had been in shields possession why
didn't Hydra try to do anything with it
this new timeline helps explain that
turns out the tesseract was missing no
one knew where it was from 1989 to 1995
but notice how in the middle of that
period 1991 is when Hydra sent the
Winter Soldier to assassinate Howard
Stark perhaps the tesseract location was
a secret that Howard Stark took to his
grave like rather than sharing
information about the tesseract to all
of shield maybe he kept it to himself
and he only shared the tesseract with
this alien cream woman he met Marvell
she would have showed up sometime in the
late 20th century and she could have
talked to Howard Stark about using the
tesseract for peaceful purposes these
two peaceful idealist silver foxes
probably would have agreed on a lot it
makes sense that Howard Stark would let
her borrow it but how would Marvel have
found Howard Stark in the tesseract to
begin with well Marvel could have
learned about the tesseract by maybe
picking up some energy signals from
Earth it seems like that's a technology
some people have or since she was
friendly with some of the Skrull maybe
there was some other squirrel's spy
embedded close to Howard Starks inner
circle who told her about the tesseract
or maybe Howard Stark himself is a
scroll Tony Stark a scroll and everybody
a Skrull who knows but we did actually
get a clue that Howard Stark and Marvel
had some working relationship remember
that tesseract hypercube doodle and
Howard Starks notes and Captain Marvel
if you look closely at Marvel's notes
she has a similar Cube doodle now I know
you're gonna say lots of us doodle cubes
could just be a coincidence but we're
talking aliens there are no coincidences
anyway after fury and goose recover the
tesseract in Captain Marvel notice how
the tesseract remains a secret to shield
your real eyes too
Colson about its actual location he
looks at very Gucci says and I'll show
up eventually in the final post-credits
scene the captain marvel goose coughs up
the tesseract on theories desk and this
can't be too long after the events of
the movie in 95 because fury still has
the same office the same CRT desktop
monitor like he probably hasn't been
promoted or hasn't been made shield
director just yet but I think we can
assume that fury kept the tesseract
close to the chest throughout the 2000s
maybe until around the moment fury
showed it to dr. Selvig and
authoritative seen and familiar we know
what happened to tesseract right
Loki shows up here X project Pegasus he
ultimately fails to take the tesseract
afterwards Thor takes it back to Odin's
vault on Asgard and in ragnarök loki
snatches it before Asgard gets destroyed
allowing Thanos to drop in at the start
of affinity war and take it from him but
Captain Marvel also fills a lot of other
blanks so the MCU timeline as we knew it
from other movies like the backstories
the guardians of the galaxy and the
Avengers in the future of endgame first
we learn the final moments in the movie
that Nick Fury named his Avengers
initiative after Carol Danvers whose
pilot call sign was Avenger so all of
his wisdom his ability to motivate these
Avengers his no-nonsense candor with
future Avengers like Stark and cap and
black widow it all began with his
experience with this pilot alien
brainwashed super soldier he's probably
been chasing that high ever since and we
know Captain Marvel will join the
Avengers in endgame and since it looks
like her powers were derived from the
space stones energy in addition to
flight and supercharged photon blasts
she also appears to have the ability to
teleport and phase shift like she
definitely got the jump a black widow
there I am Betty Betty sneaky sir and
maybe like Scarlet Witch who's mine
Stone derived abilities empowered her to
destroy the mine stone
Captain Marvel will have a similar
advantage against Thanos and the space
stone in endgame but then again dannis
might be ready for her because Ronan
also plays a role in the Captain Marvel
movie he's in cahoots with yon raagh and
of course later on in 2014
Ronan will split from the Kree military
and join Thanos in a plot to take the
Power Stone Ronan knows about Captain
Marvel and he might also know that the
tesseract is on earth because that's
what jaan raghav after so perhaps Thanos
learned about the space stones location
from Ronan and that's what kick-started
his assault on earth with Loki in the
first Avengers and if that's true then
as well
probably know that some super-powered
Kree earth lady is out there somewhere
like he knew who Tony Stark was you
gotta imagine this guy keeps a list of
potential threats
aside from Ronan we'll have to see the
other ways Captain Marvel could fill in
the Guardians timeline in my breakdown
of Captain Marvel I pointed out how the
shooting star that Carol and Monica see
in the late 80s could be yonder ship
when he kidnapped Peter quill and in
2014 quill mentioned hooking up with
some aggressive Kree girl and both he
and Carol do have troll dolls in their
possession but here's my question for
you are you more excited to see how
Captain Marvel could tie into the future
of the MCU with the Avengers or the past
of the MCU with the guardians of the
galaxy comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and ei vas and subscribe to
the new rock stars on YouTube and
subscribe to our podcasts wherever you
get your podcasts thanks for watching
and whatever Nick Fury has told us about
his past with shield Pegasus and the
tesseract remember what he taught us
about trust last time I trusted someone
I lost enough oh you thought just
because we learned how he lost his eye
I'd be done with this bit mm-hmm wrong
[Music]